estaba de visita en Polonia cuando
inició la Guerra en Ucrania cuatro días
después pudo regresar Aunque su ciudad
ya no era la misma antes de la guerra
era carpintero sin experiencia militar
hoy es uno de los miles de voluntarios
ucranianos que se han Unido al ejército
de ese país y entrenados en el Reino
Unido
Supongo que lo más difícil fue el
entrenamiento físico Porque todos somos
civiles somos gente normal no estábamos
preparados para tal carga de trabajo
físico pero en general disfruto el
entrenamiento
además de habilidades básicas de combate
ha aprendido primeros auxilios como
parar el sangrado de una herida tanto
como artem tienen un hijo que también
está en el frente de batalla
me uní a las fuerzas armadas de Ucrania
en marzo de 2022 justo después de la
invasión total para mí no había otra
opción que defender proteger mi tierra
mi país y mi familia
el entrenamiento que dura cinco semanas
está a cargo de militares británicos y
de otras naciones en el mundo en tierras
inglesas la capacitación contempla
habilidades básicas de combate defensa a
través de trincheras polígono de tiro y
lucha en zonas urbanas
definitivamente no se puede ganar sin
sobrevivir primero Entonces se trata de
enseñarles darles las habilidades que
necesitan para sobrevivir desde 2015
luego de que Rusia anexará crimea el
Reino Unido empezó a capacitar tropas
ucranianas en ese país y en los últimos
seis meses han entrenado a más de 10.000
soldados en territorio británico para
ayudar a Ucrania a ganar la guerra
[Aplausos]